[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
exploring the life of hogwarts founder
godric gryffindor of the four founders
of hogwarts there are none quite as
beloved as godric gryffindor he was one
of the most powerful jewelers of his era
with both the wand and a sword and the
students of his house have proven
themselves time and time again as
champions of the wizarding world as they
defeated the likes of gaelic grindelwald
lord voldemort and many a dark wizard
but despite his impressive legacy many
of his most famous feats and
achievements have all but been forgotten
so today we're going to take a look at
the life and legacy of godric gryffindor
and discover what made the founder of
house gryffindor so influential godric
gryffindor was likely born sometime
before the year 960 ce
in the village in the west country of
england
unlike some of his other co-founders
like salazar slytherin the exact
location of godric gryffindor's birth is
pretty easy to determine in
commemoration of his long years of
service to the wizarding community that
small village in the west country was
renamed to godric's hollow in his honor
and it was actually home to many of the
most famous gryffindors of the 19th and
20th centuries the dumbledore family
perhaps as early as 1864 resided in
godric's hollow as well as the potter
family who lived in a small family
cottage until lord voldemort's fateful
attack
during his life godric gryffindor must
have shared the same challenges as other
witches and wizards of the time
mainly the persecution of the community
by muggles who were increasingly fearful
of those who could wield magic
throughout his life godric gryffindor
surely faced the hatred of the
non-wizarding community
but interestingly when compared to one
of his childhood friends salazarin
godric never tried to retaliate in fact
amongst the four hogwarts founders
godric was the most vocal in his support
of the mughal community and muggle-born
wizards that alone has led some to
question gryffindor's own heritage
some would suggest that gryffindor might
have been a half-blood
although this is extremely unlikely one
of his closest friends was as we've
already mentioned salazar slytherin who
spent nearly his entire life working on
behalf of pure bloods as a young man in
the decades prior to the founding of
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry godric became quite an icon
with his skills with both the sword and
the wand he was renowned as one of the
greatest jewelers of the era and with
his massive broad shoulders and red hair
that was often described as a lion's
mane he was an intimidating presence in
any arena even though he could defeat
almost any opponent in a magical jewel
gryffindor often opted to use a simple
sword especially if he was facing off
against a muggle
godric took great care to preserve honor
and respect even in combat
the very traits that would go on to
partially define his house at hogwarts
some time before the year 990 ce the
year hogwarts was founded godric
gryffindor found himself in
correspondence with three of the
greatest wizzes and witches of his era
one was his longtime friend zelezar
sutherin the other two were helga
hufflepuff a witch from wales who was
highly talented in charms and rowena
ravenclaw a witch from scotland had an
infamous falling out with her own
daughter the four were already famous
for their abilities and together they
hoped to combine their skills in order
to teach future generations of witches
and wizards each of these founding
members of hogwarts had their own vision
for education and with that were given
leeway in how they instructed classes
in their early discussions it must have
been apparent that godric gryffindor
just as his reputation as one of the
greatest sword duelists of the time
seemed to indicate
hope to find the bravest and most
determined students while some members
like helga hufflepuff didn't put such
heavy burdens on freshly enrolled
students as gryffindor did and if
there's a flaw in the legendary hero of
england then that's perhaps the largest
one in creating his house gryffindor
hoped to establish a legacy that would
last for centuries to come
one centered around the warriors ideals
that he himself embodied when he
withdrew his ruby inlaid sword in combat
but when compared with our own modern
concept of education and the role that a
teacher should play in a student's
development godricks could be said to be
far outdated some might even say that
godric wrongly conflated his own delight
in dueling battles to the death as brave
so when he served as the leader of his
house he might have taught his children
to solve problems by fighting their way
out of the situation
instead of using other tactics like
diplomacy
which actually might have saved more
lives whatever your take on godric's
education philosophy may be
it's hard to deny the effect the wizard
had
while other houses like sutherin gave
rise to some of the most terrible dark
wizards the world would ever see
gryffindor brought about the likes of
albus dumbledore james and lily potter
and benevola mcgonagall as the school
grew gryffindor southern hufflepuff and
ravenclaw discovered a handful of
challenges that they would need to
overcome first of all even though
wizards and witches tended to be longer
lived in their muggle counterparts they
would inevitably die
the founders wondered how students would
be sorted in the years following their
deaths during those discussions it's
likely that the other founders simply
wanted their heirs the teachers that
would succeed them to select students on
their behalf
but gryffindor had a different idea
he popped the brown leather hat off his
head and together they imbued it with
the power to decide which house a
student would belong to this of course
is the sorting hat
but gryffindor laid another secret
enchantment on the hat and it had to do
with this sword
sometime just before or sometime during
his time at hogwarts godric gryffindor
had commissioned the creation of a
silver sword in later years it would
become known simply as the sword of
gryffindor but during that time the
goblins who had created the blade might
have known it as ragnuck's sword
after all ragnuck the first one of the
greatest silversmiths of the age had
spread a rumor amongst the goblin
community that the sword was actually
his and gryffindor had stolen it the
goblins had been so angered by the news
that a group of easily manipulated
goblin thugs tried to knock godric
unconscious and rip the sword from him
gryffindor famously withdrew his wand in
response and cast a spell on the
woefully outmatched goblins sending them
back to ragnarok with a threat of their
own
if the goblin ever tried to steal the
sword again
godric would drag its blade through the
lot of them and leave them lifeless on
their dust-covered foundry floor when
gryffindor joined the other three
founders in enchanting the sorting hat
he added an additional bit of magic
whenever a true gryffindor was in need
of help they could reach their hand into
the hat to withdraw ragnarok's sword now
godric was never highly regarded for his
mastery of divination but the
enchantment he put on the sorting hat
seems to indicate otherwise
why else would children in hogwarts need
quick access to a weapon that was
powerful enough to slay a basilisk again
the same critics of godric's legacy
might simply suggest that he was a
combat obsessed wizard of the dark ages
who couldn't quite distinguish what was
appropriate for his students but that
hardly seems to be right after all the
time of godric gryffindor was filled
with more than enough enemies to make a
young wizard fear for their life with
witch hunts looming on the horizon and
dark wizards from within the english
magical community sprouting here and
there godric had every reason to worry
for future students at hogwarts but as
the years passed at hogwarts gryffindor
faced a new challenge with his oldest
friend
salazar slytherin was becoming
increasingly intolerant of muggles and
half bloods he didn't like the idea of
hogwarts admitting anyone other than
purebloods if we look past the simple
prejudice and try to figure out why
slytherin held such an extreme opinion
it's likely due to his own painful
experience with muggles in his youth
whatever torment he faced to the hands
of the non-magical community
certainly didn't excuse his own
extremism but it does add an extra sense
of tragedy in the end gryffindor along
with the other founding members of
hogwarts decided that enough was enough
and slytherin left the school
that unfortunately was the last great
event in godric's life
after salazar's departure gryffindor
surely missed his old friend they'd
created so much together and helped the
wizarding community in innumerable ways
if only salazar could forget his
obsession with purebloods then who knows
what new heights the pair would have
achieved in the years that followed
godric likely passed the seasons in the
same way as he always did teaching the
next generations of witches and wizards
from within the walls of hogwarts
watching the seasons change time and
time again eventually gryffindor died
passing sometime in the 11th century
his legacy and the ideals of courage and
stalwartness became the bedrock for much
of the wizarding community as we know it
today without his contributions to
hogwarts it's unlikely that the world
could have survived the rise of wizards
like grindelwald and voldemort but
perhaps more interestingly the fate of
the greatest gryffindors harry potter
and albus dumbledore likely would have
turned out far darker and that's it for
this video if you enjoyed the content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel
until next time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
[Music]
you